[Music]
cameron is in houston hi cameron how are
you
hi dave hi christina thanks for taking
my call sure what's up
uh we're on baby steps four five and six
but i feel like we're a little stuck in
neutral my wife is very concerned about
using a financial advisor
she thinks she's heard too many horror
stories of
people
losing everything from other people
handling their money but i've told her
i'm i'm in need of additional guidance
and and i want to maximize our finances
moving forward
do you have any advice for
helping a sway for concerns or anything
that i could tell her or discuss with
her that might help us move forward i
love
that she's cautious about this
okay
there are two kinds of fear
fear that keeps you from playing
kickball in the middle of the interstate
where there's 18 wheelers
or touching a hot stove
those are good fears
right
and you know fears that make you wary of
crooks are good fears
um
and i will tell you this truthfully the
thing that scares me more than crooks
are well-intentioned ignoramuses that
are enthusiastic
they will screw you up with money more
often and and screw you up in life more
often than actual crooks because there
are more of them
um
and so i love her caution in that the
other kind of fear is false evidence
appearing real i once heard about a
family that had a car wreck and so i
refused to drive a car
okay that's where she is
okay okay so how do you solve that for
someone that has this fear that is um
based in
that is based in a good kind of cautious
wisdom but has gone too far the only way
i know to solve it is with information
now the way i would do that is this
if it was my wife i would say okay you
know what i completely understand
because by the way i do i can say this
truthfully i completely understand that
people sometimes get completely ripped
off by people in the financial world
because sometimes they do
but i do know there are some good people
in that world that also help people and
i don't know how to do this without some
help and so what i'm asking of you is
not that we invest money with someone
not that we make the decision to use an
advisor but that you agree
to do
three meetings
with advisor with an advisor or advisors
to learn about
that industry
because you and i don't know about it
all i'm asking you to go is to listen
and to learn if at the end of that you
remain completely opposed to it then
we'll deal with that
because here's the thing there's more
regulations on those guys dude than
there is on banks
oh wow okay i mean they are so regulated
at the yin yang it's unbelievable i
don't know how they get any work done
for the stupid feds sticking in their
ear hole all the time
it's nuts okay i mean they have to give
you a prospectus that says you're going
to lose all your money in the first 17
pages before you can even see the actual
investment analysis behind it and this
is a this is an investment that's been
open 85 years and has not had but five
down years but you still have to say
you're going to lose all your money and
they say and they make you say stupid
butt stuff like uh past performance is
not indicative of future performance of
course it is that's dumber than crap
but they make you say stuff like that
you know of course it is it's not a
guarantee of future performance but it's
the only way you do forecasting in
investments or business you have to use
past performance to do it so anyway my
point is when you get in there with a
good financial advisor and say just tell
them the truth she's scared because she
thinks there's so many crooks in this
business and tell them ahead of time
show us what the safeguards are tell us
how the industry works to protect us if
you're a crook
okay and if they're offended by you
saying that get out of their office
because i if i was in that business i
would love to have this conversation
and tell the uninitiated how
regulated that world is
um
it's it's nuts but anyway all that to
say i think the other thing that'll
happen as a sidebar is she'll see a
human being
that is that she will sense
with her spirit
is a good person or as a bad person
okay and you and you've gotta you gotta
trust her when she says that
absolutely now all of our meetings so
far have been over the phone but we do
have some in-person meetings scheduled
soon yeah so i think this will be a good
uh good way to do it if we show us the
safeguards might be the best way to just
just tell them the truth she does not
want to do this because she's afraid of
all the crooks in the business and the
stupid people in the business tell us
why you're not that or that that's not
meet with our smartvestor pros if you
can dude click on ramseysolutions.com
get with some of them because they will
relish because they have the heart of a
teacher and this is this is like you're
going to give them the opportunity to do
what they love to talk about
right okay yeah and we've done a lot of
the vetting too so we're only going to
recommend people that we trust yeah so
hopefully that but it always scares me
when we do that because sometimes people
will go in there and do business with
them just because we trust them i would
rather you trust them
you vet them you get in there but i mean
we vetted them we feel good about them
and one of the things we vetted is
they're going to have the heart of a
teacher
and so just you know what are the types
of investments i should be scared of
what are the types of people i should be
scared of and how does that work and i'm
really scared and i don't even want to
be here i would encourage her to say all
of that
and if they raise their hackles up and
are offended get out of their office
don't use them
okay
okay because i think a good one will say
rise to the challenge on this and go
i
thank you for letting me tell people how
this all works because i don't get to
tell many people how screwed up our
business is by the few crooks that are
out there
because truthfully there's a lot more
crooks in the real estate business than
there are in the financial business
because real estate business is
relatively unregulated
i mean there's a little bit of
regulation but not much and there's not
many crooks in real estate business
either it's there you know you're not
taking people's money there you're just
doing a transaction most the time so but
i mean golly i think a lot it is so
i mean i mean
and there's a lot more idiots
in the banking world a thousand times
more idiots than there are in the
financial advising world because the
tests are so hard
to get in there number one but number it
just requires a level of intellect to
get in there gray matter and you don't
have to do that to work in a bank right
well i think a lot of people get into
these situations and they feel like
they're being interviewed they sit down
with an advisor a real estate agent and
they feel like oh gosh
but it's like you are still hiring that
person like you get to ask questions you
get to dig deeper yeah you feel inept
because you don't know right anytime you
go in a situation and the expert is
there you feel like like like you know
and i but man i tell you what the best
thing ever happened to me in my life i
learned to bow up on those people
and make them prove themselves and by
teaching me right i'm not you don't need
to be my lawyer if you can't teach me
how we're going to win
you know you don't need to be my tax guy
if you can't teach me why we're doing
this and what's going on you know i
don't have to be as good as you i don't
have to know everything you know but you
got to be able to transfer the knowledge
enough that i get comfort because i'm
not doing it because you said so you
ain't my daddy right you know i said so
bull crap my money you know we're not
doing that so that's the thing you got
to get to there and i love his wife's
spirit for that reason i think it'll
lead them to really good solid
conservative investments that they won't
get screwed on that's a wonderful thing
so folks you're always looking for
someone with the heart of a teacher yes
if they're condescending
or they're offended by you asking hard
questions which is a form of arrogance
or condescension
um if they uh expect you to do stuff
just because they said so you got the
wrong people whether it's mortgage
people real estate people insurance
people
lawyers uh financial advisors you're
looking for the heart of a teacher
around the financial world and i got to
tell you more people learn how to sell
in the financial world than learn how to
teach
so they're the teachers are harder to
find and that's the only people i work
with only people i'd tell you to work
with that's good that's good yeah be
willing to look around ask those hard
questions and and really explore for
yourself i love her heart that she wants
to see oh yeah that's a good place to be
in it's a it's a healthy there's the
unhealthy side of fear that makes her
maybe not want an advisor but being
cautious and going in and interviewing
people that's wisdom yeah instead of
just going i turned it all over to my
man
i think i was different and the man lost
the money no no you are the man
you you don't turn it over
you get somebody to invite you're in
charge so i love y'all she's sitting in
the driver's seat man that's awesome